مجرمون روز يمنحون عفوا عن افعالهم
السابقه بعد ان قاتلوا سته اشهر على
الجبهه الاوكرانيه ففي الخامس من هذا
الشهر قدم رئيس المجموعه شبه العسكريه
افجين بريكوجين هؤلاء الرجال للصحافه
الروسيه قائلا انهم ولدوا محاربين واوضح
في مقطع فيديو نشرته وكاله ريان وباستا
الرسميه انهم نفذوا عقدهم بشرف وكرامه
وعليه فقد حصلوا على عفو عن جرائمهم
السابقه وفقا لبنود هذا العقد الذي
اقترحاته مجموعه فاجنر منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا يمكن منح العفو للسجناء السابقين
واستعاده جميع حقوقهم المدنيه بعد ان
يقاتلوا لمده سته اشهر غالبا في الخطوط
الاماميه في الفيديو الذي نشراته الوكاله
لم تكون وجوها هؤلاء المجندين واضحه لكننا
نراه صافحون رئيسه مجموعه فاجنر ويستمعون
الى ملاحظاته لكن ما حقيقه هؤلاء يقول
بعضهم انهم وجدوا في فاجنر عائلاتهم
الحقيقيه خاصه ان العديد منهم نشا في دور
ايتام وارتكب جرائم اختيالات ومخدرات
وجريمه منظمه بعض وسائل الاعلام المعارضه
استعرض التفاصيل الجرائم التي ارتكبها
هؤلاء في ما نقلت هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه
عن احد المعارف الشخص منهم بانه رجل عنيف
للغايه مستغربا رؤيه شخصا مثله يعاملك بطل
لكن افقيني بريكوجين قائده مجموعه فيجنر
له وجهه نظر اخرى فهو يرى ان هؤلاء الرجال
كانت لديهم مشكله مع فائض هرمون
الاجيرنالين وقد حصلوا على فرصه ثانيه في
الحياه وانه وجودهم مع قوه فاجنر افضل من
ارتكابهم لجرائم جديده نشر الفيديو جعل
خبراء يطرحون استفهامات بشان الرسائل التي
تريد موسكو ايصالها من خلال الكشف عن
هويتها هؤلاء
وتقديمهم بصفه ابطال وعن مخاطر وجود
مجندين في ساحات الحرب مجردين من العقيده
العسكريه والاخلاقيه
[موسيقى]